is it perfect timing cool Vibes or can
Spider-Man just not miss at the box
office for all these reasons and more
across the spiderverse blew the
competition away some superheroes are
pretty obscure and some are Spider-Man
regardless the first spider-verse asked
a lot from viewers centering on a spidey
had never been tested on the big screen
in addition to focusing on Miles Morales
he was also one of the first modern
superhero movies to embrace the concept
of the Multiverse bringing a whole crew
of obscure takes on Spider-Man and
making them front and center compared to
live action tempoles starring the likes
of Tom Holland or Andrew Garfield as a
familiar Peter Parker this Spider-Man
Adventure arrives somewhat under the
radar that's not the case this time
around thanks to great reviews I called
it maybe the best Spider-Man film ever
made the original movie won over Legions
of new fans in their living rooms
building a Groundswell of excitement
that had the sequel opening to a far
larger potential audience as a result
across the spider-verse will likely
surpass the box office total of its
predecessor and a fraction of the time
with the 2019 Oscar win for best
animated feature and a plethora of other
accolades into the spider-verse was too
successful to be called a cult movie but
it nonetheless collected a substantial
Cult of die-hards AS Slash film puts it
the sequel's success speaks volumes
about how the audience for the first
film exploded over the last four years
keep in mind this trend is likely to
continue across the spider versatile and
dously play well in fans homes for
months to come winning over yet more new
converts who will be pounding at the
theater doors in March 2024. thanks to
this movie's many Cliffhangers no one
who sees it will want to miss a grand
conclusion promised by its own upcoming
sequel beyond the spider verse out of
all the recent Spider-Man movies into
the spider-verse was the only one to
have made less than 700 million dollars
worldwide nonetheless this reported
final Hall of over 375 million dollars
represented a healthy profit when
compared to the movie's 90 million
dollar budget for over two decades now
Spider-Man movies have been as close to
a sure bet as you can get in Hollywood
regardless of who stars in them or how
well they're received by critics and
audiences Peter Parker's appearances in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe have also
come in some of its most lucrative
installments Captain America Civil War
Avengers Infinity war and Avengers end
game which combined made about 6 billion
dollars the original spider-verse opened
relatively modestly for Sony netting
over 35 million dollars at the global
box office and winning the weekend on
the back of its familiar branding after
that movie when so many fans over the
sequels opening weekend blew it out of
the water raking in well over three
times as much money with 120.5 million
dollars went into the spider-verse
premiered moviegoers who weren't steeped
in the source material may not have been
exposed to the concept of a Multiverse
while there were stray Sci-Fi movies and
TV shows that dealt with alternate
realities the word Multiverse was rarely
if ever used and the concept was far
from the center of the Zeitgeist are you
from another dimension like a parallel
universe where things are like this
universe but different in in your
Spider-Man in that universe but somehow
travel to this universe although the
notion was vaguely referenced in 2016's
Doctor Strange the mcu's Multiverse
didn't really get kicking until after
2019's Avengers end game phases four and
fives interdimensional stories like Loki
and Doctor Strange in a Multiverse of
Madness brought the concept heavily into
the overarching plot that means into the
spider-verse should get substantial
credit for making Multiverse as
mainstream consider this only four years
after that film served as a Multiverse
primer everything everywhere all at once
a live action film about the concept
when seven Academy Awards including best
picture in the Years between the first
and second spider-verse films the notion
of infinite planes of existence has
become commonplace enough that it almost
feels like a cliche audiences probably
didn't buy a ticket to Spider-Man across
the spiderverse specifically because
they love multiverses so much it's a fun
favorite character and the phenomenal
animation the other stars of this series
but because multiversal storytelling is
more of a place in popular culture than
ever before selling audiences on the
fundamental concept was easier other
than ever well history shows that people
go see a Spider-Man movie regardless of
the reviews it certainly helps if the
buzz prior to release is as strong as it
was Spider-Man across the spider verse
on the heels of opening weekend it's
Rotten Tomatoes score jumps straight to
95 making it one of the most acclaimed
major Studio films of the Year its
audience score went even higher at 96
though Spider-Man into the spider-verse
settled into a slightly higher 97 Rotten
Tomatoes rating many critics called the
sequel even better than the original in
their write-ups fan sentiment has been
equally effusive and the only thing
bringing down these rave reviews is the
film's abrupt ending it's 2 hours and 30
minutes yet is effectively the first
half of a story that will resolve itself
in next year's Spider-Man beyond the
spider verse the release of Spider-Man
across the spiderverse was delayed twice
initially a teaser advertised the
premiere date of April 2022. the back
got bumped back to October then Sony xx
finally settled on June 2nd 2023 though
the postpone humans were frustrating to
fans eager to see Miles Morales in
action again it might be a case of good
things coming to those who wait the move
gave the creative team more time to get
across the spider verse just right and
it provided the movie with a choice spot
on the calendar with school letting out
and families looking for something to do
across the spiderverse only had The
Little Mermaid in its second week to
Grapple with the Super Mario Brothers
movie and Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
was still in theaters says at the time
of its release but they weren't the
juggernauts they were weeks prior coming
later in June are DC's The Flash and
Pixar's Elemental both of which drop
into Cinemas on the 16th the former has
strong bursts but a potential problem to
overcome on its unbattled star Ezra
Miller bad reviews out of canned poured
cold water on the prospects of Elementor
neither is tracking anywhere near the
spider-verse sequels opening weekend
totals all of which should allow the
Spidey sequel additional weeks to
dominate the box office and pad out its
total earnings While most radical
animated movies these days are rated PG
the vast majority of superhero and comic
book movies are rated PG 13. about PG-13
rating however doesn't necessarily stop
parents from bringing younger children
to see say the latest installment of the
MCU sometimes word gets out that a PG-13
film is too much for some kids to handle
Dog District in the Multiverse of
Madness and Guardians of the Galaxy vol
3 both push the envelope when it came to
horror adult situations and humor okay
now what open the door like the original
Spider-Man across the spite of us has
rated PG but brilliantly positions
itself in the gray area between an eye
dazzling kid's cartoon and more adult
oriented dark superhero territory this
gives parents of children who might
still be too young for some of Marvel's
racier titles peace of mind sure the
Artistry and the emotionality are far
more mature than the average animated
movie but there's minimal objectionable
language no gross out moments and no
blood across the spider verse is packed
full of good role models and positive
messages about what it means to be a kid
and a parent it's well deserved PG
rating plus its overall quality and
relevant themes make it perfect for a
family outing just because Spider-Man
across the spiderverse is appropriate
for single-digit Aged audience members
doesn't mean older teens and adults
won't be entertained yes that's a
cartoon yes it has messages about family
and identity but absolutely nothing
about across the spider versus simple or
sugar coated visually and narratively
the film is equal parts authentic and
edgy miles and gray and face complex and
sometimes gut-wrenching problems that
don't have obvious Solutions whole
stretches of the movie are downright sir
which is skillfully reflected in the
animation style and color palette the
humor is also sharper than one would
expect from a PG movie writers Phil Lord
and Christopher Miller are known for
being able to deliver rapid fire gags as
they did in The Lego Movie another PG
rated film that manages to be PG-13
Style funny the jokes are smart
subversive and fun and the plot which is
remarkably unpredictable for a kids
movie keeps fans on their toes and
trying to guess what's going to happen
next the film's PG rating welcomes a
youngest subset of viewers while doing
nothing to deter the demographic that
usually prefers more complex PG-13 and
are rated movies kid movies and
superhero movies are perfect
opportunities for merchandising and
product placement every time one comes
out brand new Affiliated items can be
found on store shelves and at fast food
restaurants Spider-Man across the spider
verse is no different tied to its
release Burger King offered a limited
time BK verse menu you that featured a
red burned Whopper and a spider-verse
ice cream sundae the Whopper sold out
within days selling out even faster when
new across the spider-verse Branded Air
Jordan 1 next chapter high tops gone in
less than an hour are those my Jordans
I can't help it if we're the same size
merch builds hype among the most devoted
fans and collectors but not everyone
cares about these kinds of promotions
just because Burger King Lego and Nike
are household name brands doesn't mean
everyone is desperate for a red
hamburger bun or a pair of 200 sneakers
these types of promotions do however get
a film's name out there logos and images
of plastered on store windows and
internet browsers and people
subconsciously become aware that a movie
like across the spider verse is coming
soon for all the planning that goes into
making a movie there's one thing that
matters that's almost beyond the
Creator's control is it cool the cool
factor is kind of intangible and it's
not the kind of thing that you can force
if a piece of Pop Culture becomes cool
to engage with talk about make memes
about is impact on pop culture gets much
larger as it builds an audience no one
wants to be left out across the spider
versus undeniably cool but this
impossibly High cool Factor didn't come
out of nowhere miles Jordans and Gwen's
Converse are well established eternally
cool Brands the creative flourishes and
in jokes are cool Lord a millirakul the
voice actors all range from well known
to Beloved the original soundtrack by
Metro Boomin and the spider verse for
the famous collaborators is pretty cool
as well but perhaps the coolest thing
about across the spider verse is a new
Surefire breakout fan favorite character
spider Punk otherwise known as Hobie
brown spider Punk has depicted in a
faded out two-dimensional collage of
poster scraps reminiscent of the Sex
Pistols ascetic among others played by
Oscar winner Daniel kaluya he has a
thick Cockney accent and when he takes
his mask off miles can't believe he's
even cooler underneath it's no surprise
that the terms Hobie and spider Punk
were trending on Twitter upon the film's
release or the fan art is already
proliferating across the internet most
people who saw across the spider verse
on opening weekend only saw it once but
you can bet many will be seeing it again
this is one sequel that begs to be
rewatched for multiple reasons first the
art the music the script and the voice
acting are so layered and complex fans
want to pull further on some of the many
threads that appear only briefly second
though the armor moments where the movie
slows down to have a moment of human
connection most of it moves so fast
audiences leave a first viewing feeling
as though they must have missed
something the sequel is overflowing with
Easter eggs callbacks and cameos
sometimes multiple references share the
same frame there are Illusions for the
first movie allusions the live-action
Spider-Man movies Illusions the Lord of
Miller's other movies nods to comic
books nods to video games as of yet
unseen variants of Spider-Man and a
number 42 appears more times than anyone
could reasonably catch the first time
around there are even editor notes like
in the comics which sometimes appear
when vanish too quickly for viewers who
don't yet have the benefit of a pause
button taken as a whole this ridiculous
level of rewatchability should help
across the spider-verse day out or near
the top of the box office throughout the
first half of the summer